[Music]
chuck i got another idea for an
explainer
okay
now i've tinted to this probably in in
different other explainers gonna give it
its own topic now and it's simply why
does ice float
um okay because i'm gonna say because
um
your girlfriend is um holding you while
she floats on the board
i know she's to let you go
you know she doesn't love you enough to
keep you on that board
what does that have to do with ice
floating no i'm sorry it's a it's an
iceberg reference to titanic oh no we'll
get there we'll get there all right
so
why does ice float so the simple obvious
answer is that it's less dense than
water and anything that's less dense
than water will float
okay
okay period a second wait wait anything
one second go anything less dense than
water will float yes
let's say you have a boat made out of
cement
or iron or steel which they do
ha
steel is definitely more dense than
water yes it is so there you go
suck on that mr
astrophysicist or know it all
okay it was a major advance in military
operations
to figure out you can make a boat out of
steel
rather than out of wood
because then that would make the side of
your boat impervious to cannonballs
right or any other kind of sort of
traditional weaponry that would take out
the wood planks of the side of your boat
when we figured that out it completely
transformed
naval forces and naval power
and so
it's odd that we didn't figure it out
earlier than we did because the the
physics was there um but it just take
you know you just need genius people to
be born and contribute their knowledge
so
that's all okay that's how you mean
okay so here's the thing the entire
object has to have an average density
that's less than water
okay
so so the steel boats are not made
entirely of steel you know why because
they have an empty hull all right
there's air inside air inside of them
so i see so the totality of the boat yes
with the hull being mostly hollow full
of air yeah
the entirety of the structure is now
less dense than water yes because when
you take it in its totality yes and you
sit it in the water
it won't go down because really it's the
air that's kind of that's really helpful
and even in aircraft carriers that that
are fully loaded with missiles and
weapons and torpedoes and airplanes that
are under deck
still most of that space is air it's air
right right it's not tight packed
airplanes right uh with the wings folded
up there's air all around them there's
air in the offices of the captain and of
the you know of the ship uh sailors so
the total average density has to be less
than water and you get that by mixing
the steel and the air together there you
go okay there you have it
and so so it's like so take that mr
funny man
all right
all right so so that's that's how that
works but by the way we should be
reminded how heavy water is
all right uh you don't think about it
because a cup of water you just lift it
but
what's the heaviest thing
you're gonna lug out of a grocery store
uh your gallon of milk or water no
there's heavier things than that heavier
than that you're gonna lug it in the
summertime i'm gonna say uh fettuccine
alfredo that might have been frozen
that's very heavy always gives me
problems after i eat i think the single
heaviest thing you're gonna haul out of
a grocery store is a watermelon
okay
okay it could be yeah and they're big
i always do that secretly because i'm
black yeah i know yeah you can't nobody
can see it i can't let them see me
buying the watermelon
somebody's going to get a picture of it
and they're going to exactly
[Music]
all right so
um but if you toss a watermelon in a
swimming pool
it'll float it floats yeah oh yeah
you're right yeah yeah so watermelon is
less dense
than water okay okay and by the way it
doesn't float bob up like a cork no it
floats low
right because but that just means its
density is kind of near that of water
but
but still less than it yeah okay which
would make sense hence the name
watermelon well yeah exactly exactly
so
so you know another famously heavy thing
are
tree logs
okay
yeah you know you know you know so the
paul bunyan split you know log splitting
activity well that tree segment
somebody somebody have to have to lift
that up onto the chopping block okay
that sucker is heavy yes it is okay it's
heavy before you sort of start splitting
the wood into quarters for the fireplace
yeah as a matter of fact it's so heavy i
just had a tree removed from my backyard
and i've never seen a tree cut let the
record show chuck does not live in the
city okay
so i i
i've never seen a tree come down before
like you know uh from start to finish
and so they cut it down in sections and
the last section looks like a giant
stump
because it is yeah and then that portion
that they cut off they let fall
and when it fell
it made a thud that shook my house
i've never seen anything so heavy in my
life hit the ground and they didn't tell
me and it drove a big divot the length
of the stump in the ground i mean i
can't tell you how heavy trees are if
you were to go there and pick up that
toppled stump
and chuck it into a lake
it would float it would float yeah
exactly i'd also be getting my powers
from the yellow sun
thank you jorel
i'm jorelle's illegitimate cousin
they call me black kyle
that's the one who was living out in the
shed right
you came to earth later
kyle was messing around
with the help
his name was kyle schwartz [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so
uh so my point is
whether something floats has nothing to
do with how much it weighs
at all
it has to do with what its density is
that's my i wouldn't make that point
okay all right and so and wood is lower
density than water and so all wood
floats basically unless it becomes
water-logged then it might sink but it
floats and that's why old loggers before
we had cars and trains and things would
log trees near rivers
and then they'd
roll the the trees
down to the river and the river would
carry the logs down to some port um
where they would then be milled and
that's how you get a log jam right a
literal logic because the logs would
bunch up right and then someone would
have to be there at those nodes and
release them and then all the logs would
then continue floating down okay so but
not has anything to do with why i
started this explainer which is why ice
floats it's why ice floats so what
happens is unlike most things
that
shrink when they get colder
believe me i know that okay most things
shrink why because the vibrating
molecules take up space
and as you get colder the vibrations get
get more constrained and so the the it
shrinks
i'll remember that the next time i step
out of a pool okay
so it's just vibrating molecules
that's you could be here it's not me
it's a vibrating molecule
so that's why if you look at bridges for
example if you walk across a bridge
there's always places where these these
sort of teeth joints
that can expand and contract allowing
the bridge to not buckle with the
temperature changes okay so that we so a
lot of construction is conceived and
built to accommodate the expansion of
contraction from the heating and cooling
of objects okay
water is the exact opposite of this
okay no so when water gets down to the
freezing temperature so here's what
happens okay
water
does shrink when it gets colder
now i only know these temperatures in
celsius because it's a science-y thing
so we got to go
switch over to celsius water freezes at
zero degrees celsius so watch what
happens the water does
shrink
as you cool it
by tiny amounts and it expands as you
heat it by the way part of the global
warming problem
is that if you heat the oceans the
oceans expand even if you don't melt ice
into the oceans the oceans will take up
more volume and flood the coastlines
simply because it the temperature is
higher wow all right and and if it makes
it a half a one percent difference in
the volume of the water
and you have a three mile deep uh um
ocean
what's how much higher is one half of
one percent of three miles relative to
your coastline okay a lot it's it's a
lot so the water is getting denser and
denser and denser and denser
it gets to four degrees celsius it's at
its densest
aha okay oh it's getting crowded will
get very crowded okay and at that
temperature if it's at its densest that
water drops to the bottom
of the lake let's talk about a lake now
that water drops to the bottom every
next
generation of water that hits four
degrees sinks
sinks i see where you're going with this
now okay
so now there's now we're kind of done we
get to three degrees two degrees one
degree
zero degrees we begin to freeze
and frozen water
has expanded 10 percent more than the
water that it came from okay
so that frozen water is floating on top
of everything right
okay
so
here's the most astonishing fact
you will learn today maybe this month
maybe this year
okay all right
ice
insulates
the water below
from the dropping temperatures
as you enter winter
so
all that four degree water that went to
the bottom
is now shielded from getting any colder
from the layer of ice on the top from
the layer of ice on the top so you build
ice and the ice can get thicker and
thicker and thicker but it'll stay on
top
if you're a fish in that lake
if you're a fish you say let me just go
lower
so in the winter
all the fish stay alive in a frozen lake
because they're hanging out at the
bottom
that doesn't freeze
if water were like every other substance
and you froze it
at the surface it's now denser than the
water around it it would sink to the
bottom
you would freeze the lake from the
bottom up
and all the living creatures and the
fishes would be there flapping for
oxygen and then they'd all die
wow
rapidly
so the fact that water
gets bigger when it freezes
protects life
in colder climates that survives the
winter at the bottom of those lakes that
is awesome and i gotta tell you you're
right that's almost as shocking as when
i learned that i had a new
son okay all right so that's up there
it's pretty up there
and he just showed up like bing bong hey
it's me
[Laughter]
so
so this is a profound fact that is a
property of the water molecule yeah
water markets as we'll call them special
properties and so now it is possible to
completely deep freeze a lake because
eventually you know if the lake is small
enough um and and the winters are long
enough and if you completely defreeze a
lake you kill everything okay but the
larger lakes do not go through that
phase and they will retain their their
wildlife for for that reason that's
great yeah so so oh and
wait a minute if ice expands 10 percent
that means an ice cube
the part of the ice cube that's sitting
above the liquid level of your drink is
about 10 of the volume of the ice cube
that makes sense
so 90 of your ice cube is below
that's why every time you fill an ice
cube
i mean the ice tray to its very top
when you come back to it you have a
solid slab
of ice
that you now have to break you know and
yeah yeah because it went over the
dividers of the ice thing right exactly
because it expanded up to do that ended
up yeah right right so this is why
icebergs what are icebergs made of
ice ice thank you so whatever you see
whatever you see 90 of it is below the
ground
which is what took out the titanic
basically it wasn't the size of the
iceberg they saw it was the size of the
ice that was below the water level and
in the original
night to remember uh titanic movie
um they show this huge iceberg that the
titanic collides with if it was that big
they wouldn't have not seen it right saw
it from miles away
but
cameron did it right okay james cameron
in the 1996 or seven um version he there
was like a little ice cube a little
bitty ice thing there okay they couldn't
see it and they sailed towards it and
they they know it's bad but they didn't
see it until it was too late and it was
what was below the ground that ripped
out the thing and so and by the way
you're right because in the movie the
iceberg rips the hull yes it's not that
they collided with it it's that as they
went around it it grabbed the side of
the ship and ripped it open as it ripped
it off so the point is if you try to
make a movie and it's hollywood and you
want people to be afraid of the big bad
iceberg the earlier movie was 1950
something
showed a huge iceberg and say oh my gosh
we're all going to die and that's not
how icebergs work
and so james cameron is scientifically
literate in many ways and in many
dimensions and
and if you if you remember the scene
where jack and rose or one of them uh
they s the the
they felt that they hit the attribute
they quickly ran out and looked over and
it's just this little icebergy thing
going by yeah right right yeah um
there's one look at that icebergs and
gangster
again don't see my ones don't see my
guns
they got it all below the surface
that's that's how ice rolls and it's a
it's a fun remarkable
thing and oh also of course this is why
you need to leave 10 volume in any
liquid food you're freezing in your
freezer
interesting yeah if you can't fill it up
to the top and put it in the freezer
you'll break
the container
yes okay because the water when it
expands
nothing is going to stop it
right it could be made of steel
it will break this is how you break
pipes
uh copper pipes in the winter the water
gets in there and it begins to freeze
and
bada bing is the pipe 10 bigger than it
was before no so it's got to bust a hole
in it now it can become ice
wow look at that yeah
all right so chuck let's kick it up a
notch okay instead of water 101
let's go water 201 all right
if this is like inside baseball inside
the water molecule so watch let's say
you invented some new substance some new
kind of container that is
unbreakable
and you put water into that container
filled it to the top sealed it and put
it in the freezer okay
who wins
who wins when that water wants to expand
because everything else we've got with
water busts out of your pipes it'll
break your glass it'll bust your
champagne glass which is very heavy duty
okay you try to cool champagne too
quickly put it in the freezer that
sucker freezes pop
pop
okay
so
the indestructible container meets the
immovable force or the however that goes
irresistible the force meets the
indestructible container who do you
think wins
i you know i always bet on water
yeah
okay here's what will happen oh wait how
about this let me let me just take a
guess
the water will refuse to freeze
correct okay
correct
the chat i love you man i love you i
love you chuck yeah
let me give you a kiss and a hug okay
so what happens is the container the
indestructible container will not allow
the water to expand so it stays water
stays water it stays water
against the wishes of the molecules so
it stays water even and you can take the
temperature down to zero we're in
celsius land again zero five below ten
below it'll stay
water right but here's the cool thing
why won't you let me be what i wanna be
that's why i hate you dad
that's why i hate you
you can't accept me for who i am
what's this with you in this therapy
session
[Laughter]
it wants to be
and it's in a container that won't let
it i'm just trying to be ice that is who
i am
that is who i right down to my molecular
makeup man
and you will not let me be me
so
watch what happens so you pull the
container out of the it's now like a
zero degrees you now have zero degree
water
oh my gosh
what is that okay
so now now you have a magic device okay
that like either dissolves the casing or
unzips it or whatever okay
in that instant
the entire vessel of water
freezes into ice
in a fraction of a second look at that
because now it has the room to expand
and it does it in that instant wow look
at that so in the pipes in the copper
pipes just to be clear
they didn't break at 32 degrees or 31
copper is a copper pipe is pretty strong
okay
it was holding on to that
and if you ever notice pipes don't
freeze when it hits 32 degrees right or
even when it's in the 20s that's not
when pipes break
okay
when do they break we're down when it's
in the teens
and the single digits where the water
finally says my power to break you
old copper pipe becomes greater than the
the strength of the copper pipe itself
so the copper pipe will sustain liquid
water down below a freezing temperature
it has some strength to it that's all
i'm saying here yep it's like i'm here
i'm ice i don't care if you are nice
okay i'm breaking you
oh is that your attempted poetry
i figured i'd go for something
i was just trying to something
i had nothing for that you had nothing
for it i had nothing for breaking a pipe
okay
look these can't these can't all be gold
people that's right
[Laughter]
so there you have it chuck that's ice i
would say ice in a nutshell
but no it's that's more ice than
probably anyone cared to hear no that
was fascinating that's really good stuff
well one last thing about floating ice
okay
that
the less dense it is the more above the
water line it'll float that makes right
so a cork is like really sitting high up
there and styrofoam barely goes in at
all right whereas the watermelon sank
very low and there's like you know just
a fraction of its diameter there
and so so so there you have it and
that's how you can make a canoe you know
the native americans would hollow out a
wood because the wood floats hollow it
out it'll float even better it floats
then we learn
uh aluminum which is a light metal but
it sinks
hollow it out
so now you make a canoe out of metal
right because now you put it in the
water and you sit in it you sit down the
total density
is less than the density of water so the
canoe floats you float in it everybody's
fine there you go
that's oh yeah well i mean
i'm not going canoeing anytime soon but
okay but i'll tell you canoes in their
noses in the tail in their nose have um
uh flotation
cushions and nut cushions but um there's
like styrofoam in the nose and the tail
of the canoe
all right
and
so you ask why is that there
why is that there
can you figure it out well i guess
because it adds like it makes it harder
to yeah it's buoyancy because it's no
because
if you just left air in there that would
be more buoyant than putting anything in
there oh okay so then that you'd be too
light
no now you got a surfboard
now you're flying
look the reason that's working is
because the canoe only floats
with the curved side down
right okay if you capsize ah you don't
sink your canoe okay exactly because the
canoe is fricking made of aluminum okay
so if you capsize it the middle fills up
with water and the whole thing will just
sink to the bottom but instead it floats
because it's got the little hollow out
you got the hollow that it's not just
hollow
hollow it's got this
right with floaty floaty styrofoam in it
and basically it's floaties for your
canoe
it's like arm floaters
if it was airtight they could just have
it a pocket of air and then they
wouldn't need it but the canoe was just
sort of welded in spots so so there you
have it chuck way too much about water
we went way long on this explainer yeah
this was a good one yeah yeah so
i gotta go i'm really thirsty see ya
all right another star talk explainer
about stuff you didn't know you should
care about
and maybe still don't
neil degrasse tyson here people come out
[Music]
you